hello and welcome to the 20th episode of
footnotes I'm here to recap the most
ravishing ideas from around Wired first
up today mermaids
the most beautiful things in the ocean
unless you can see the bottom half of
them which is all scaly and gross this
came up in RAW files recap of their
favorite viral photo projects of the
year which included a piece on
professional mermaids at a Florida
amusement park shown here getting ready
for a fencing match
apparently in various cultures mermaids
can be a force either good or evil but
none seem to give a damn about not
swimming for a half hour after eating
obviously they're nothing more than
legend but that didn't stop Animal
Planet from releasing a documentary
earlier this year
pretending that they were real
apparently Animal Planet has redefined
animal to include creatures that only
exist if you're a drunk sailor in
reality supposed mmmm sightings have
typically either been dugongs or
manatees which belonged to the order
Cyrenian this group of animals takes its
name from the sirens of Greek mythology
these were fowl temptresses who lured
sailors to rocky deaths and who woke me
up in the middle the night when I lived
near hospital a few years ago and indeed
mermaids are closely associated with the
sirens except sirens are usually on
shore because they're afraid to get all
pruney in the ocean so remember sirens
always bad mermaids
sometimes bad sometimes good and we'll
plan it never to be trusted again unless
you're a drunk sailor up next hybrids
that really exists and that therefore
actually belong on Animal Planet in the
December issue of the magazine were
introduced to the plight of an
endangered pup fish which could be saved
by bringing it with a similar species
this would of course be a totally
awesome story when their grandkids asked
them how they met such a hybrid would
join a multitude of other somewhat
freakish animal amalgamations both human
bred and natural
so we have the zedonk a cross between a
zebra and a donkey and the wolf in the
offspring with false killer whale and
bottlenose dolphin which is a pretty
self-confident hybrid that was somewhat
embarrassed by that nose
the dolphin can mate with the false
killer whale because like the Orca the
latter isn't a whale it's actually a
dolphin and the bottlenose thinks it has
really pretty eyes also of note is the
kama a cross between a camel and a llama
this was discovered by Boy George who
found several of them hang out with a
chameleon hybrids often turn out to be
sterile and thus will not proliferate as
a new species in the wild as it happens
Homo sapiens may have once bred with in
neanderthal
so we humans could technically be
hybrids if this is true mermaids are in
fact double hybrids part human part
neanderthal and part fish but all woman
and maybe some see me